je veux pas qu'on ait changé l'est ats
[Musique]
j'aimerais qu'ils eric antoine où nous a
fait une petite surprise mais avec plus
j'aimerais que nous face aux tours de
magie parce que vous l'attendez touche
contemporaine
alors quel est le héros tu veux ici
c'est chez toi c'est ton émission c'est
ta chance et tu ton émission cyril non
tu es pas très grand mais je t'aime
beaucoup ok je veux pas qu'on ait changé
l'est le micro le micro n'importe quoi
c'est la première mission en échange des
nestes qui est une musique sans rigoler
on
[Musique]
et il va le fêter les un micro quelques
pommes il est dans ton slip on a deux
[Musique]
merci je te fais alors qu'est ce que tu
veux tu peux des nattes tu veux quoi
qu'est-ce que je te fais à toi un
d'accord alors lui en fait il n'est pas
du tout âge et sont effacées rire des
avions également juste à côté
donc merci d'être là merci bébé chéri
j'ai fait un tour dans votre hommage
pourquoi pas ce que j'écrivais ce genre
2 et d'à côté regardez bien il y a des
cartes bien sûr mais il ya surtout des
noms de famille des chroniqueurs ici 2
et aussi bien sûr de gilbert et d'alex
ya vers des zéros sonia malagré ya
moronou naya lemoine et ses
embouteillages ou devient compagne est
tous copains d'ici et le que theillet
les prénoms il ya une oreille et thierry
vous pouvez remarquer d'ailleurs
l'ordre est tout à fait différent bah
oui c'est à dire que si je prends le roi
verdez là c'est qu'ils rouen b le roi
c'est aussi verdez je vous explique le
truc pour qu'on soit sûr et certain que
c'est bien mélanger deux sièges mais
même leur mélange et une fois comme soit
le douaisis mélange ta race si tu vas
toucher une carte du bout du doigt
accor tu touches celle que tu veux tu
n'es pas compris c'est la première fois
qu'on fait un tour ensemble celle là on
l'a fait dépasser on a bien carte
ok parfait on la met comme ça regarde
bien le dépasse comme ça regarde bien
ici bien pas de correspondance gibert
chamerois ça n'existera régime benhaim
non ça n'existe cousin qui fait des
intrants combal enfin rien et si de
tutoyer aucune correspondance
on a une carte que tu as choisie et qui
est exactement celle là que je mets de
côté je te montre qui a toujours aucune
correspondance et regarde bien fait rire
aux eaux parce que je dors à elven verde
et me regarder ça n'existe non annonce
tu aimerais que ça existait dans son
ferme
on regarde bien sûr cyril j'aimerais que
tu regarde la carte que tu as choisie
qu'est ce que tu as choisie comme carrie
choisi le moine me moinat et regarde
l'autre moitié
normalement ce serait jean luc c'est
normalement mais non et c'est jean le
cam en la maintenant que ça a été choisi
par cyril que le chef d'equipe à toucher
regarder maintenant gilbert rozon jour
arroser maintenant
c'est fort l elysée
ah bon
[Musique]